des milliers d'hommes se sont succédé
ici il en mourait tous les jours de
nouvelles fournées combler les rides se
confronter à l'horreur pour ne jamais
oublier dès l'été 1945 six mois après la
libération du camp d'auschwitz ce film
est diffusé en france dans le cadre
d'une exposition voulue par le général
de gaulle le début du devoir de mémoire
l'exposition est appelé les crimes
hitlériens et vaduz radio sur place à
auch suisse à une époque où le papier
est rare c'est ici que nombre de
français découvriront pour la première
fois les camps de la main des français
confrontés à la réalité des camps de
concentration mais aussi au témoignage
de rescapés dans les livres d'abord puis
à la télévision dès les années 50 dans
l'émission lecture pour tous l'écrivain
elie wiesel déportée avec sa famille
livrer son histoire chaque fois que rim
apple pas qu'il marchait pas bien l'opal
commencer par le bas des récits
douloureux mais nécessaire selon ces
survivants réunis sur le plateau de
l'émission les dossiers de l'écran 1970
vingt-cinq ans après la libération des
camps d'extermination
cet homme rappelé l importance de leur
témoignage pour les nouvelles
générations en quelque sorte de
transmettant un message et nous nous
demandons que ce message soit écouté
pour que jamais plus le monde ne revois
des choses pareilles jamais plus la
auschwitz jamais plus de camps de
concentration
transformée en musée dès 1947 le camp
d'auschwitz devient rapidement un lieu
de mémoire rescapés pellerin chef d'état
du monde entier viennent faire face à la
cruauté des camps des voyages scolaires
ils sont aussi organisées dès les années
80 une prise de conscience pour ces
lycéens français finalement qu'est ce
qu'on est venu faire ici ce s'être face
à face aux vikings vérité qu'il a fallu
accepter en 1990 en france
la profanation du cimetière de
carpentras ravive la nécessité du devoir
de mémoire des musée de la résistance et
de la déportation se multiplient dans
les villes françaises à l'initiative
d'associations mais à cette époque pour
certains le devoir de mémoire est encore
trop insuffisant pour qu'il soit totale
ce journaliste eux réclamaient une
reconnaissance souveraine des crimes
perpétrés par le régime de vichy
il sait pas s'il a quelque chose
d'extrêmement grave dont la france
n'arrive pas à se souvenir et ne veut
pas se souvenir et pour cacher ça qu'est
ce qu'on fait on fait des cérémonies
consensuelle le pas est franchi le 16
juillet 1995
dans son discours au vélodrome d'hiver
jacques chirac est le premier président
à reconnaître la responsabilité de
l'état français dans la déportation et
l'extermination de juifs durant la
seconde guerre mondiale une nouvelle ère
pour le devoir de mémoire
[Musique]